the wreckage of the early morning
aberdeen to glasgow train
lies crumpled and burnt in a remote
valley
carriages are crushed one on top of
another
one lies meters away and appears
partially burnt out
tragically three people died including
the driver
astonishingly just six people were taken
to hospital and
none of them are believed to be
seriously injured this is a tragic
incident
and first and foremost our thoughts are
the families and friends of those
who are very sadly died this morning i
would like to reassure the public that
this was not a busy service
and from cctv inquiries and witness
statements we believe all passengers
have been accounted for
however once the area has been made safe
then our full and thorough search will
be conducted
the emergency services were called at 9
43
in the morning three hours after the
train
had been due to leave aberdeen just 20
miles north
it said there were just six passengers
on board
smoke could be seen rising from the
scene as scores of emergency vehicles
descended on the isolated location
including coast guard and air ambulance
helicopters
a major incident was quickly declared
this is devastating news this has been a
really tragic
incident and my condolences are with the
loved ones of the three people who have
lost their lives and that includes the
driver of the train
clearly this is an ongoing operation
i've just been
briefed by network rail and the
emergency services on that
but devastating news for the bereaved
but
also for those who are on the train and
my best wishes go to
those who sustained injuries i
understand none of those injuries
are life-threatening but this will have
been a dreadful experience
the area had been hit by torrential
thunderstorms overnight
flooding was reported in several parts
of scotland
and pictures have emerged of standing
water on the tracks near the accident
scene
investigators have the difficult task of
establishing
how this could happen to a train that
had already been significantly delayed
and was traveling through curving
steep-sided cuttings
just hours after such heavy rain one
area of investigation
will be the condition of the track and
its surroundings
i think what we'll have to do is wait
and see what the british transport
police
come up with how what exactly they
identify as the
as the cause of this derailment and
and you know working with network rail
with everybody make sure
nothing like this happens again network
rail was warned about the network's
resilience to severe weather just
four weeks ago the annual health and
safety report by the office of rail and
road
said there'd been a six-fold increase
last year in flooding events on
britain's railways
it said there'd been a spike in
landslips demonstrating what it called
the vulnerability of the network
meanwhile the tragic death of the driver
in this disaster makes the urgent
investigation
more difficult search teams will be
examining the wreckage when it's safe to
do so
but they believe everyone has been
accounted for
answering all the questions about how
this could have happened
will take weeks and months
gerard sky news aberdeenshire